تكتمت كييف على انطلاق هجومها المضاد لكن
ملامحه كانت واضحه منذ ايام
25 معركه تحدث عنها الجيش الاوكراني
بالقرب من بخمه شرقي البلاد وجنوبا بالقرب
من افديفكا ومارينكا في دونسك وقرب بيلو
هوريفكا في منطقه لوغانسك وفق رويترز
ميدانيا حققت القوات الاوكرانيه مكاسب في
المرحله الاولى من الهجوم المضاده
مكاسب وصفاتها صحيفه وول ستريت جونل
الامريكيه بالصغيره مقارنه بحجم الاستعداد
والتسليح الغربي طيله الاشهر الماضيه
بحسب الصحيفه فان الهجمات الاولى كانت
مكلفه حيث دمرت مركبات قتال ودبابات اضافه
الى تخلي القوات الاوكرانيه عن ناقله جندن
ومركبه قتاليه لكن تمت التفوق لاسلحه
القوات الاوكرانيه الغربيه على الروسيه
خصوصا في الهجمات والعمليات الليليه
فالاوكرانيون اختاروا الهجوم ليلا لتقليل
فعاليات القوات الجويه الروسيه وتجنب
هجمات المسيرات وفق تقرير لصحيفه
ليبراسيون الفرنسيه غير ان المعادله تتغير
نهارا فتنكشف تحركات الاوكران
انكشاف مكن الروس من تحقيق ضربات مباشره
لدبابات ومركبات المانيه وامريكيه الصنع
استخدمتها القوات الاوكرانيه
اعترفت بذلك لكنها قللت من حجم خسائرها
خسائر دفعت بيكييف للطلب من المانيا زياده
عدد الدبابات ليوبارد الى ثلاثه اضعاف
اضافه الى مركبات قتاليه وصواريخ كروز
بعيده المدى
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات